[Music]
the Meg with Jason Statham was a true
surprise hit in 2018 and offered plenty
of fun action in 2023 the sequel was
supposed to pick up where the movie left
off and once again attract the masses to
the movies to watch giant monster sharks
so it's high time for a small preview of
the Meg 2.
first we'll turn our attention to the
plot the second part of the Meg is
supposed to tie in with the predecessor
in terms of story content but will be
even more brutal and terrifying than the
original let's take a brief look back at
what has happened so far the first part
story revolves around deep sea diver
Jonas Taylor who actually specializes in
rescue missions however when a gigantic
prehistoric shark attacks a submarine
Taylor has to put all his skills to the
test to save the crew from the Megalodon
a creature that is supposed to be
extinct he is supported by the
oceanographer Dr minwei Zhang and his
daughter Su Yin because it's obviously
quite difficult to take out the largest
shark that has ever lived the scientists
quickly realized that the giant creature
probably originates from a huge ocean
trench that was opened as a result of a
thermal explosion the team around Jonas
Taylor finally resorts to underwater
bombs and manipulated Torpedoes however
the Megalodon manages to wreak havoc on
an entire beat section and kill
countless people in the end the crew
succeeds to injure the shark after which
it is eventually attacked and killed by
other sharks after the events the main
characters Jonas and suyun then first
decide to go on vacation the second part
is also to be based directly on the book
original by Steve Alton as the author
already affirmed in 2018 this could
avoid the same fate that befell the
sequels to Jaws in the case of the cult
series there was only one book on which
the story was based and that was quickly
used up Alton in contrast has published
eight the Meg books so far which is why
it seems only logical that the Meg 2
will be based on the second book called
the trench in this book a new gigantic
sea creature appears that spreads fear
and Terror the talk is about a
chronosaurus which is not bigger than
the Megalodon but likes to hunt in
groups and is thus clearly more
dangerous the main character Jonas
Taylor not only has to deal with this
new enemy but also with an offspring of
the Megalodon named Angel the Angels
meanwhile become a tourist attraction
but threatens to escape from Human
captivity at any time so Taylor and his
comrades won't get bored anytime soon
and the audience can again look forward
to plenty of shark action in all shapes
and sizes
since filming of the Meg 2 the trench
already started the beginning of 2022
the cast is well known of course we will
again see action icon Jason Statham in
the leading role he is joined among
others by Cliff Curtis's Mac shuya
Sophia Kai as Mei ying and Paige Kennedy
is DJ new to the cast are Resident Evil
actress Sienna Guillory as the leader of
a research project American Horror Story
actress Skyler Samuels is a new member
of Taylor's crew and Sergio Paris
menchenta who played in snowfall will
portray a hard Edge mercenary
there are also new people behind the
scenes on the one hand John Turtle Taub
the director of the first movie has been
replaced he has succeeded by Ben
Wheatley who last directed the horror
flick in the earth in 2021 and was
signed on by those in charge following
the success of his Netflix film Rebecca
the production will once again be led by
Transformers producer Lorenzo di
buonaventura as well as Belle Avery who
was also involved in the first movie
those of you enjoyed the score for the
mag can also look forward to composer
Harry Gregson Williams once again let's
wait and see what we can expect from the
planned theatrical release of Meg II the
trench on August 4th 2023
[Music]
thank you